- Thank you to the Salt Lakes for welcoming us to All-Hero Weekend.
As a special treat, taverns will be open till 8 p.m.
- I've never got so many cheers!
I'm so excited.
- Why's Steph here?
Everyone knows I was brought in to replace him.
- He thinks he can replace me.
Cute.
[Growling]
- Look, LeBron's courting the second-hottest young guard.
[Whispering]
- But King, you already have DLo.
- LeBron, step away from the impressionable young star.
- Thanks, Dame. I almost had to go to a place
with pressure and expectations.
- I've battled too many superteams.
Some less super than others.
And I vow no superteams will form this All-Hero Weekend.
- Not this loyalty s--t again.
♪♪♪ Born to be a hero ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Riaru-sa misetayo ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Born to be a legend ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Hikari o mezashite ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Born to be a hero ♪♪♪
[Saxophone Rat squeaks]
- Hmm.
- I've used it many times, it's never failed me.
- LeBron! Aw, did I ruin another one of your trades?
- [Chuckling] Maybe it's me, or maybe it's you.
- [Groaning] [Wall crumbles]
- I know you think you clutch.
I'll show you clutch.
- Dame, calm down.
You're not supposed to activate it.
Not at All-Hero Weekend.
- [Announcer:] Welcome back to the celebrity All-Hero game.
Post Malone struggles down the court, and-
[Energy burst]
- Oh, nice beam.
- It's... Dame Time.
May God have mercy on us all.
[Whispering]
- [Dame:] No. More. Hand covering mouth...
[Energy charging]
Whispering things!
Bombs away! [Blasting]
- [Grunting]
[Muffled explosions]
I knew this would happen.
Before I came here, I knew this would happen.
- [Echoing] Sixteen bars.
[Wooshing]
- Dame, you're right about superteams.
Everyone should follow the old ways of heartbreaking losses.
- Heh.
[Glass shattering]
- Hah!
[Sand cascading]
- Sorry, Dame.
You were destroying the Salt Lakes,
And none of us wanna be part of that rebuild.
[Crowd cheering]
- [Announcer:] Wow!
Best All-Hero Weekend yet.
- Nice bag of tricks you got there.
- Woah, careful. No superteams.
[Laughing]
- [LeBron:] I've used it many times,
It's never failed me.